those are the kind of things I've heard
my whole life though is you know what we
need to solve everything is a plan for
me
politician whoever and all my buddies
and we'll make sure this will bring
people downtown if we just put this in
like a lot of cities with dying
downtown's Cleveland is desperate to
revitalize its center city
Cleveland's leaders have bet huge
amounts of public dollars that
big-ticket attractions will spur
economic activity during the 1990s
Cleveland marketed itself as the
comeback City and invested hundreds of
millions of taxpayer dollars in the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame and stadiums for
the Browns Indians and Cavaliers City
Cleveland is expert at building big
white elephants and calling that
economic development and it doesn't work
because if you look at the stadiums you
notice the building surrounded or empty
the politicians who champion these
corporate welfare projects promised that
they would stimulate the local economy
and on the face of it that's precisely
what they appear to do 120,000 some
people down there looking for parking
looking for places to eat tipping the
waiters tipping the the valet guys sure
there's more action around the stadiums
on game day but economic studies
consistently find that these kinds of
publicly funded projects fail to
increase the overall economic activity
you're basically taking the
entertainment dollar of a Cleveland er
and saying they're gonna spend it here
as opposed to there in pro sports it's
common practice for team owners to
threaten to relocate if they don't
receive public funding and Clevelanders
know all too well what it's like to lose
a beloved team but for a cash-strapped
city like Cleveland the price is too
steep you think a city whose school
schools are crumbling whose roads are
crumbling whose bridges are falling
apart whose economy is in terrible shape
and you're going to subsidize a
billionaire team owner somehow it
doesn't make sense to me city officials
have not learned their lesson the city's
next redevelopment Silver Bullet is a
new Convention Center that will require
hundreds of millions of additional tax
dollars I don't know Cleveland was such
a bustling convent
city take that vegas funded by an
increase in the county sales tax the
hope is that the medical mark convention
center will attract medical conventions
to cleveland lots of people are
skeptical that the plan can work i
personally don't agree with it maybe I'm
wrong but Pittsburgh built a convention
center and it's like an acre
this whole tendency to put what our
scarce public funds into convention
centers the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
these sort of ephemeral projects is a is
delusional Cleveland wasn't a tourist
destination in its best days it's
certainly not going to be a tourist
destination and it's close to worst you
think a city like Cleveland would
welcome any company with open arms
especially companies that aren't asking
for handouts but guess what happened
when retail giant wal-mart came to town
wasn't asking for all sorts of new tax
breaks or new subsidies all wanted was
the ability to operate and the response
of the political process and a lot of
local political activists was horror
political activists put pressure on the
City Council to change the zoning
regulations in a dilapidated underused
section of town called the steel yards
to prevent the superstore from opening
in Cleveland Dave's market a unionized
grocery store chain in Cleveland had the
most to lose the belief was Dave's would
somehow be compromised or unfairly
competed against if God forbid another
store would open would would offer
similar products at lower prices after
some political maneuvering Walmart
ultimately opened up for business in
Cleveland and unless you're a committed
anti-walmart activists it's hard to
argue that Walmart has been anything but
good for the city
there was a line when they when they
first opened up the interviews thousands
of people seeking these jobs jobs that
we had been told during the debate we're
going to be low wages and and and poor
quality jobs but yet thousands of people
thought that these jobs were
significantly better than the other
opportunities they had when I come down
here I may go to Home Depot
most of the time when I come down here
I'm coming to Walmart they got
everything I need and more but you like
Walmart all I know is every time they
open a Walmart there there's an
Applebee's right around the corner
that's okay with your care and what
happened two days market realizing they
couldn't compete with Walmart's low
prices the closest store changed its
name to Dave's mercado and now
specializes in foods for the growing
Latino community in the area that's good
too
restrictive zoning regulations are the
weapons of choice for the powers that be
in Cleveland if it's going to be a
residential neighborhood and it's going
to be a residential neighborhood if it's
gonna be single-family homes than
single-family homes it is and then you
know down the street you can do
something else you can do condos you
could do a high-rise apartment building
or something fancier like that but that
just seems to be the way things work
here it's a very Planning oriented place
so what's the alternative Houston is
booming in part because the city doesn't
have heavy-handed land-use policies
let's just face it when you go to a city
with zoning what happens is once the
land is zoned the process to permit the
process to build and get approvals in
certain cities in this country can take
years
Houston's freewheeling approach to
redevelopment wasn't very popular with
the Cleveland lawmakers we talked to
Houston effectively has no
yeah that's right it's a joke you know
and Houston if we were to adopt that
model you could put a pawn shop in the
middle of residential neighborhood and
we don't want that
Houston certainly does have its quirks a
case in point is the beer can house the
lifelong passion of Houston beer drinker
and artist John milkovisch it's not
perfect believe me but a lot of ways
it's allowed Euston to grow more freely
this is a zoning map of Cleveland the
city with 22 different zoning
designations and this is a land-use map
of Houston where people are free to use
their land as they please cities don't
need central planners for redevelopment
to happen in fact without zoning
restrictions growth happens organically
and that's the kind of growth that
creates vibrant ethnic and
entrepreneurial communities you go to
Houston you drive on Bel Air Road and
it's filled with dim sum places and
Vietnamese restaurants and and
spontaneous redevelopment isn't the only
benefit of minimal land use regulations
a part of Houston is sort of free market
approach to land use regulation is that
we don't try to force all of our
commercial skyscrapers downtown we let
them kind of set up wherever they like
and and that has led to a clustering of
various job districts around the city
sort of a decentralization having
multiple business districts eases
traffic considerably but most
importantly Houston's liberal land use
policies encourage redevelopment by
reducing costs for developers approvals
at City Hall and then permitting I think
we can do it about half the time that
you can around other parts of the
country and that's flexibility and that
lowers a person's cost the top-down
approach to redevelopment hasn't worked
in Cleveland or anywhere else it might
just be that Cleveland needs more
Walmart's and fewer convention centers
and fewer rules telling businesses where
they can and cannot set up shop and
having goods what themes is a good
having people go to cultural
destinations is a good thing but if you
don't have economic vibrancy
you're really not answering the
fundamental question we can all make our
own decisions we don't all want to live
our own kind of life you don't need a
centralized government tell us what to
do all the time and it tell us you know
what color to paint our house and what
you know what we can put where we'll
decide on our own we'll work it out with
our neighbors on our own